face à la nouvelle concurrence très
forte du football féminin le handball
doit défendre sa zone pour trouver la
relève de l'équipe de France et
améliorer sa formation dans cette équipe
junior participant au tournoi
international à Poissy ce week-end plus
de 5 joueuses évoluent déjà en Division
1 face à l'Italie les Bleus ont dû
retard à l'allumage la défense
effrayable mais au fil des minutes les
fils d'Eric Barada montant régime et
continue de perfectionner leur phase
offensive
mais bon on a su garder la tête haute
pour ne pas baisser de régime on a
essayé de d'être constante même si on
avait du mal à quelques moments du match
malgré leur manque de fraîcheur physique
en seconde période et une attaque
transalpine plus efficace les Tricolores
maintiennent un écart minimum de 7 buts
elle s'impose finalement 24 15 et valide
leurs qualifications pour le championnat
d'Europe l'essentiel c'était déjà de se
qualifier donc en gagnant ce match là on
est déjà qualifié pour les Championnats
d'Europe le deuxième niveau c'était de
d'avancer dans notre projet de jeu
aujourd'hui je m'attendais à une avancée
assez difficile elle existe mais elle
est effectivement petite parce que quand
on a deux matchs en moins de 24 heures
comme ça on a joué à 20h30 hier soir on
rejoue à 17h aujourd'hui c'est un petit
peu compliqué d'enchaîner dimanche les
Bleus remportent le tournoi après leur
troisième victoire face au Portugal
30-21 et peuvent nourrir de solides
ambition pour ce premier championnat
d'Europe junior de l'histoire